the hills above loch ness
and on the bun loiter state they're
cutting down trees for the good of the
planet
these spruce were planted several
decades ago on a peat bog but scientific
analysis has shown the peat is now so
dry and damaged that it's releasing more
greenhouse gases than the trees are
absorbing and on balance the trees have
got to go
it is a bit counterintuitive
but we have to take down our plantations
that have been planted in the wrong
places like on our peatland bogs and
restore that as a habitat in itself
and we have to
manage our woodlands better so that they
are meeting biodiversity targets
comprehensive measurements of carbon in
the estate's trees peat and grassland
have underlined how important nature
could be in mitigating climate change
the bun loita state is just 1200 acres
in size yet it stores the equivalent of
more than 1.2 million tons of carbon
that's two percent of scotland's annual
carbon footprint and it'll be released
if nature degrades
scotland is a man-made wilderness
centuries of sheep grazing sport
shooting and tree felling have shaped
the landscape now estates like bun loit
are trying to rewind the clock and
rewild nature
camera traps reveal the estate's hidden
wildlife restoring nature would be a win
for biodiversity the climate and green
jobs about 60 000 trees are grown in the
nursery each year different sorts of
ones mainly for the very high ground the
nursery at the organization trees for
life gives clues to the scale of their
ambition they want to replant half a
million acres linking estates across the
highlands to the atlantic the highlands
are beautiful but in many ways they're
an ecological desert much of what should
be here isn't here anymore but there are
remnants there are patches of the
original caledonian forest beautiful
peatlands that can be restored and
nurtured and be the sort of source of a
wider landscape change they're coming
around now
but not everyone's convinced angus
mcfadden has 1300 ewes several dozen
cows and he says plenty of wildlife on
his farm he doesn't see the sense in
covering good land with trees
these hills that i'm farming on because
of legislation that's there now couldn't
take trees i'm talking about things like
the depth of peat the steepness of the
banks
we couldn't plant cheese on there so
better a good moodland management scheme
proper grazing regime
to help store the carbon
at bun loyt they're hoping to show
rewilding farming and forestry can
co-exist but it'll take generations and
funding to replant the highlands and use
scotland's landscape to hold back the
climate crisis
thomas more sky news loch ness